moving from uh from covet and masking to
uh for just a few minutes to go to
andrew cuomo
who is stepping down from the
governorship
and uh and and i think a a pretty
surprising development i didn't expect
that he would actually step down um
although in hindsight
it it makes sense because the entire
political machine had turned turned
against him
and i think
you know for any democrat when they're
in that position
they're not going to know what to do
because it is so unprecedented
right they don't have a play in the
playbook for that
all of the all of the plays that
democrat politicians have in the book
all come with the assumption
that they're going to have the media on
their side
and all of the cultural institutions on
their side
they don't really have a play for when
that goes away because it almost never
does
you know it's like if you have if you
have a an offense in football that's
predicated on having a really good
offensive line and that's what the media
is for democrats they're playing
offensive line they're playing they're
they're kind of blocking
criticism and scrutiny and everything
else
well when your office is predicated that
way and then your whole offensive line
goes down with injuries now you're in
trouble because you you weren't
factoring that possibility in really
and that's what happened andrew cuomo
was kind of out on an island um after he
uh lost all of his lead blockers and he
decided to step down here he is uh we
have the clip of him announcing
that he is i think we have a clip
yesterday he is announcing that he's
stepping up but he doesn't apologize or
anything and he does make himself the
victim but here that is
in many ways
i see the world through the eyes of my
daughters
cara moriah and michaela
they are 26 and 26
twins and 23
and i have lived this experience with
and through them
i have sat on the couch
with them
hearing the ugly accusations for weeks
i have seen the look in their eyes
and the expression on their faces
and it hurt
i want my three jewels to know this
my greatest goal
is for them to have a better future than
the generations of women before them
it is still in many ways a man's world
it always has been
we have sexism that is culturalized and
institutionalized
my daughters
have more talent and natural natural
gifts than i ever had
i want to make sure that society allows
them to fly as high as their wings will
carry them
oh jeez andrew what are you doing
it's too late for this bud it's too late
for all this
but again this is the only play he has
in the book as a democrat he doesn't
know what else to do
he thinks he's got to save himself
somehow by
doing the girl power shtick now
the greatest people i know are women
men are scum the women are the greatest
they will fly as
high as their wings will carry them
women are angels flying through the sky
graceful beautiful specimens while we
men are down here in the muck
we disgusting men
it's it's it's no good it's too late you
lost
your team abandoned you this is it
android i don't know i don't know what
to tell you
um and speaking of his team the media
now has flipped to being very much
anti-cuomo which is an interesting
development in general because he is a
democrat also it's it's hard to think of
immediately anyway any recent example
of
someone crashing and burning like this
going from such highs to such lows
politically in such a short amount of
time it was only a year ago
that the media was
almost literally singing his praises
as as as choirs of angel singing praises
for the lord almighty i mean that's
that's almost what they were doing
he was he was winning emmys he was
he was on book tours
he was being hailed as the greatest most
popular politician in the country a year
ago and now he's on his way out the door
let's go back and this is always fun to
do go back through memory lane
and uh just remember here's a a
compilation was put together by someone
not me
of uh the media
extolling
the virtues of andrew cuomo and all of
these clips are again not all that long
ago let's watch this
david we're standing by for governor
cuomo's press conference's daily
briefing how would you contrast cuomo
and president trump's handling of the
crisis
truth versus mendacity governor cuomo
out there day after day after day
everything trump isn't honest direct
brave real leadership of the kind the
president of the united states should
have provided governor cuomo
is clearly living in a totally different
reality
the actual one
than the president of the united states
governor cuomo has become a national
leader for a lot of people andrew cuomo
has become the leader of the democratic
party he is conveying incredible
strength you spoke to national guard
troops today in a stirring speech that
if i wasn't listening carefully i
thought you would sending soldiers off
to war this has been a remarkable show
of leadership by governor cuomo in
recent days he's providing hope
but not false hope governor cuomo i
think is is one of the heroes on the
front line with all of this adulation
that you're getting for doing your job
are you thinking about running for
president andrew cuomo who has a daily
television show now
and has become in some ways the shadow
uh president maybe trump is just a
little bit mad that governor cuomo has
become a kind of acting president
dealing with hardship actually makes you
stronger that's what governor cuomo said
earlier today that's what i'm gonna go
teach my kids right now at home
he probably did it too
that goober he probably went home hey
kids
i want to tell you something that
governor cuomo said today
he probably really did that
um it it
this was never going to last when you
think about it and it was even weird at
the time
not because andrew cuomo was actually a
disaster as a governor and he was
directly responsible for thousands of
people dying especially elderly people
in nursing homes um that's not what made
it weird to see the media singing his
praises because the media sings the
praises of horrible democrat politicians
all the time
um who have over seen you know horrific
disasters that have led to to many
people dying i mean that's that's a
normal thing
but what made it strange is that
andrew cuomo is
you know an old white guy
and
yeah they like biden but they've never
they've never talked about biden
in the same kind of terms that they you
were using for cuomo
and generally this kind of adulation
he's a hero he's this and that that is
reserved for
non-white especially non-male
people
so in some ways
it never could last this couldn't
continue
and now they've all turned on them why
did they turn on him that's an
interesting question we can only
speculate
um
if if i had
if you'd asked me that question months
ago when this thing first broke then the
sexual harassment scandal at the time i
figured well they're doing this because
they want to cover and distract from
the nursing home scandal which they
realize is the greater scandal and most
importantly it's a scandal that
implicates more than just governor cuomo
because many democrat governors across
the country did the exact same thing
including in pennsylvania
and other states as well and so i
thought well maybe that's what this is
about
uh they need to take them down first
they need to get them out of the picture
for something to take the heat off of
the nursing home thing because they
don't want to talk about that and so
they're using sexual harassment but now
you know months later no one is really
talking about the nursing home scandal
anymore unfortunately he survived that
and yet they're still they're still
trying to take him down and they
succeeded and they're celebrating it and
it probably has a lot to do with 2024.
uh they don't want him to be the guy in
2024 he was flying a little bit too
close to the sun so they had to take him
out maybe that was the reason
but the fact is
that the media now is happy that he's
that he's gone
um
doesn't matter what they were saying a
year ago or six months ago they're happy
now
the left is happy that he's gone
and that's why when i look at this i get
a little suspicious
and when i see conservatives celebrating
that governor cuomo has got his
comeuppance i think maybe maybe we
should slow down a little bit
i mean i'm perfectly happy to see miss
fortune befall governor cuomo like
anybody else because he's a horrible
person was a horrible governor
but is this really
a win for the right
so if i got to be the guy as always
finding the dark cloud within the silver
lining then i would say
what actually happened here
what happened governor cuomo escapes any
consequence for the nursing home scandal
democrats avoid scrutiny for other
democratic governors who had the same
scandal
me too feminists get to claim a scalp
because they take him down for this
instead of the nursing home thing
while
a female
planned parenthood endorsed leftist
kathy hokul is the the lieutenant
governor she gets to take over
so is that actually
a victory
is that something we should be
celebrating
there's there's a very good chance the
person taking over will be a lot worse
than cuomo was
and will do the bidding of the left much
more than he did
and i i you know i was i was making this
point yesterday on twitter and i was
told by several people that oh well
kathy hokule
was she was endorsed by the nra back in
20 i think it was like 2010.
yes that means that she's uh she's a
moderate democrat come on
please stop
you think
you think
that the media would be happy as they
are
about an actual moderate demo do you do
you think a that a moderate that an
actual moderate democrat
could even be the lieutenant governor of
new york right now
yeah she was endorsed by the nra like 10
years ago around the same time
that that barack obama was defending
traditional marriage let's never forget
that he did that not all that long ago
his first term in office he was
pro-traditional marriage he was a
defender of traditional marriages first
term in office uh so around that time
kathy hulkiel was and i'm sure i'm
saying her name incorrectly doesn't
matter uh cathy hokkie was was was being
endorsed by the nra and then
after after uh becoming lieutenant
governor she turned around and pushed
for gun control
and publicly accused anyone who is a gun
rights advocate of being a stooge of the
nra too afraid of the nra so that's what
the nra got for their trouble for
endorsing this woman she just turned
around and stabbed her right in the back
okay she took the the the
the shank out and shanked them right in
the in the back when they weren't
looking
that tells you a lot more about the nra
endorsing a new york democrat than it
does about the new york democrat herself
but she is endorsed by plant paranoid
and i can guarantee you right now
that she is going to be more ideological
and more of a leftist
than andrew cuomo was
so word of warning
on one hand yeah it's it's nice to see
him go down for this but on the other
hand
um
it might be a loss for andrew cuomo and
that's what you're celebrating it is not
really a loss for the democrats they're
happy about this this works out for them
um and they're and they look they play
the game
i hate to say it but it's true that the
left and democrats they play the game at
a different level from most
conservatives and republicans
which is why many conservatives can't
see this as anything but a great thing
well he's a democrat and he something
bad happened to it's a good thing
[Music]
democrats are playing at a different
level
and they're thinking five steps ahead
maybe we should start doing the same
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content